For those who watch the Quick Start class on Sequencer, this will seem a little familiar,
but for those who have not, let's take a little time to explore some Sequencer fundamentals.
So what is Sequencer? Simply put, it's Unreal Engine's non-linear editor and animation tool
designed to supply users with the production tools they'll need to produce animation, trigger
various events like luprinse code, and smoothly transition between gameplay and linear animated
content. Sequencer is commonly deployed to build shots, generate pre-visualization,
manage animation in Unreal, and construct film sequences in game cinematics. From a workflow
perspective, Sequencer leverages actors from the level and gives them a set of instructions. But
as the director, you must cast which actors are going to be used. Actors can be added to
Sequencer throughout the Outliner or Content Browser to create level sequence assemblies.
These level sequence assemblies are essentially a populated level sequence. So what's a level
sequence? Essentially, it's a virtual data container. It stores various actors and their
associated attributes, keyframe data, lights, cameras, and other edit information. Level
sequences can also contain other level sequences to create nested hierarchies capable of replicating
film sequences, shots, and departmental organization. They are represented in the level as a traditional
clapboard icon, and in Sequencer itself, level sequences are represented as traditional film
strips similar to what you'd see in a non-linear application like Adobe Premiere. Sequencer
is also capable of exporting edit decision lists and XML data to synchronize Sequencer
and your third-party non-linear editor together. As you begin your journey into creating content
for Unreal, one of the first concepts you'll need to learn is the idea of actor persistence
within your environment, or in Unreal what we call the level or sub-level. Essentially,
Unreal has three different ways actors can be controlled in Sequencer. This control determines
when actors are available to the animator for animating and how long they'll persist
in the level over time. Today, we're going to primarily examine two forms of persistence,
possessibles, and spawnable actors. Possessible actors persist in the level indefinitely and
can be controlled or shared by multiple level sequences. If you know you have specific actors
or characters that will be used regularly, keeping them as possessibles makes sense for
ease of access and repetitious use. It should be noted, however, that possessible characters
can only be controlled by one level sequence at a time. Spawnable actors only exist within
an active level sequence. They're identified within Sequencer and the Outliner by a lightning
bolt icon. This type of persistence is excellent for temporary actors who are needed for specific
needs within the shot. Perhaps some extra lights, or a background actor who shows up just for the
shot and then is no longer required. The idea of spawnables are appealing because it can keep
your level clean and its environment free of unnecessary actors when they're no longer required.
The last type of persistence is replaceable actors. This blueprint-driven form of persistence is
dictated by the binding lifetime track and allows you to swap out actors within Sequencer as needed.
Let's switch over to the engine and take a look at how these concepts work.
Alright, we'll begin inside our SEQ-105-02 map. Once it's loaded, you'll see that we have a lot
of actors inside this level. There's a road, a road sign, a really nice landscape and some trees,
and then there's a motorcycle. Anything placed into the level has the potential of becoming a
possessible actor by default when it's brought into Sequencer. Whatever it is, Sequencer can
possess that actor and give it instructions beyond the actor's original attributes in the level.
Once the level sequence is done with it, the possessible actor returns to its default state
as it originally was within the level. So let's take a look at this in a demonstration. So we'll
go and create a level sequence. We'll call this LSTest. Now this is a parent level sequence,
or what Epic likes to call it, a level sequence with shots. You can double-click on the icon and
go into the Sequencer UI and we're going to add a shot track. Now the shot track is unique in that
it allows you to nest level sequences inside of a level sequence. So to do that, just click on
the plus button and we'll say create new shot asset. This is shot 0010 underscore 01 or just shot 10
for short. Now this will create this filmstrip icon inside of your level sequence. This is basically
an empty level sequence and we're just going to trim it down a little bit, maybe make it 65 or so
odd frames long, move it over just a touch, and then we'll create a second level sequence and we'll
call this one shot 20. We'll do the same thing. We'll trim a little time off of it here and at the end.
Now these two empty level sequences can be entered by double-clicking on the filmstrip icon. So if I
want to go into shot 10, it's just double-click. And you can see that we're inside of shot 10,
nothing's in here. It's empty. But if you look at the breadcrumbs over here on the right, you have
LS test and shot 10. Now at this point, you're going to want to start to add actors into your scene
and I'll go ahead and select the Unreal bike and say add actor to sequence.
So now that the Unreal bike is in here, it's been possessed by shot 10. And I'm going to go
and just lay it down on its side, raise up the front just a little bit. And I don't even need to
set a keyframe on this. But when I go back to the LS test master, as long as my time marker is
inside this level sequence, the bike will be on the ground. But as soon as the time marker goes
outside of the level sequence, the bike returns back to its original state. Now,
I'll go into shot 20. And I will add the bike again to this shot.
I'm going to do something a little different with this one. I'll go ahead and bring it to the center
of the road, bring it closer to camera. And I'll rotate it around
and stand it upright. And I'll set a keyframe
and another keyframe. And I'll push it down the road.
I'll also go and change these keyframes to linear. Now if I press play and play this level sequence,
you'll see that the bike animates down the road. Now, when we go back into our master,
you can see that the bike is being possessed by the individual level sequences that are active. So
here, at the beginning of the sequence, the bike is in its natural default state.
As soon as it hits shot 10, it lays down on its side. Here it goes back to its default state.
And then in shot 20, it travels down the road. Now, these level sequences can be moved any
point in time. So if I want to make shot 21st, I can do that. And if I press play now,
we'll have the shot going down the road and then laying down on its side.
Now, something else to remember is that these level sequences, if they're stacked on top of each
other, the shot that's on top takes precedence. So in this case, shot 20 has the bike traveling down
the road. And then as soon as it hits shot 10, it goes and lays down on its side. And then when
the shot 10 is over, again, back to its default state. Now, when it comes time for spawnables,
it's a little bit different. Spawnables, if I go inside of this level sequence,
all we have is the Unreal bike. But I want to go ahead and add in another character or
another actor that I eventually want to turn into a spawnable. Well, if we go into the content
browser, and we go to say, our assets, characters, actually, we'll go into mannequin here.
Characters mesh, and we'll put mannequin into the level. Now, this has been added to the persistent
level. And if we look inside of sequencer, and we press play, he will just be there throughout
all shots. He's in the level just like the road sign is, the road, the trees, and so forth.
But if I go into shot 10, and I select mani, and I say add actor to sequencer,
now mani has been possessed by shot 10. I'm going to delete the control rig. And I'm going to move
mani into place. So I'll just rotate him around 90 degrees. I'll move him over next to his bike.
Now, in order to change this into a spawnable, you need to right click over mannequin and go to
convert selected bindings to spawnable actor. Now you'll see that mannequin has a little
lightning bolt icon next to him. And I can proceed by giving him some animation. So I'll click on
the plus button here and I'll look for a walk cycle and stretch it out.
And then I'll set some keyframes on mannequin as well.
And you know, he's walking down the road because maybe he's run out of gasoline for his motorcycle.
And we'll convert this to linear. So if I press play here,
mani will be walking down the road. Now let's go back again to the level sequence with shots.
You can see that mani is now disappeared out of the level. It's because he's been converted to
spawnable. So as the time marker moves, shot 10, mannequin manifests for shot 10.
And he has been spawned and he'll continue to be there as long as shot 10 is active.
But as soon as the time marker leaves shot 10, mannequin disappears, everything goes back to its
default state. And in shot 20, the motorcycle drives down the road. Now this is an advantage of
spawnables in that you can see it keeps our level clear of unnecessary actors. You know,
if you have a bunch of possessibles inside of the scene, they may clutter up, you know,
what you can see or what you're viewing inside of your level sequence. And you might have to
turn them on or off, shut off their visibility or move them out of the way of the camera. And that
can be a little bit annoying at times. So using spawnables is a direct way of just basically
turning them off for only what you need. And you can use spawnables for anything. You can use it for
actors like Manny, or you can use them to generate spawnable lights, additional cameras, and so forth.
All right, this completes this individual demo. And we're going to move on to our next module
in which we're talking about some core structures within Sight of Sequencer.